sin duda alguna Lionel Messi es el
hombre del que más se habla Aquí en esta
copa mundo de Qatar 2022 Messi que junto
con Julián Álvarez y Hernán a la
albiceleste para imponerse en esa
semifinal contra Croacia por tres a cero
un partido con un valor muy especial
para la pulga porque Messi consiguió su
gol número 11 con la camiseta de la
selección nacional superando el récord
de Gabriel Omar batistuta también Messi
igual lo récord absoluto del hotel
mateus con 25 partidos en una copa mundo
un Messi que después de ese partido dijo
que este mundial el de Qatar va a ser su
último mundial Messi que va a disputar
su sexta final de una copa mundo
vistiendo la camiseta de la selección
absoluta será también la sexta final
para la camiseta Argentina Así que pase
lo que pase este domingo en esta final
ya sabemos que esta imagen la de Messi
va a quedar para siempre impregnada aquí
en Qatar Así es Juan Ahí está acompañado
de la gran estrella Leo Messi pero
hablemos el partido de hoy Francia
Marruecos también imperdible
definen ellos dos el rival de Argentina
con Francia hay noticia porque el
presidente de la federación francesa de
fútbol Noel dijo que tanto Adrián Javier
como de yupa americano centrocampista y
defensa figuras claves de este equipo se
han recuperado de ese malestar que de
malestar que registraron por culpa de la
aclimatación que en el país con
Marruecos de las noticias que finalmente
la aerolínea principal de este país
anunció que los vuelos especiales que
tenían pensado fletar para este
miércoles finalmente no los van a enviar
desde Marruecos hasta aquí hasta doha
por un impedimento de las autoridades
cataríes según la agencia serán
finalmente siete vuelos en total
adicionales los que han partido entre
ayer martes y hoy miércoles desde
Marruecos hasta aquí a Qatar para los
aficionados de Los Leones del Atlas